whenever i see
the great british bake off which is
friday night
i go into a
i'll just go to any bakery and i'll just
buy bakery stuff and i'll go crazy i
think that's the greatest show ever made
i love this season it's so good i
haven't watched the season yeah indians
are so good
there's always why are indians so good
at [ __ ] bread
have they won
one guy oh wow yeah
is my energy low no i think mine is
should we start over no let's keep going
uh i feel like the energy is low can we
try another like sound effect intro it's
just weird i was like i was like bracing
myself for what you'd say after you said
indian
her whole body would you said it why are
indians so good at making bread her body
went why why
why
why why why why did that when i say that
why would that make a cringe no i was
i was scared of what you what you would
say after you said the word indian oh
you thought i was going to say punjab or
something like that oh no yep
exactly
yeah i would never say i've never said
punjab i have it in my life who was
punjab you know who punjab was so you
ever see annie
yeah yeah she had one asian chauffeur in
the movie
but then he oh she had an indian guy i
think he's indian
his name was punjab oh was he he was he
was mystical
yeah that was good and i believe that um
the music was much better with him in
the movie yeah yeah i don't know what
that means
i think we should start off
i don't know what that means fact check
yeah
what annie right let's get closer to
punjab yeah and he was a black guy which
is weird yeah it was kevin clash it was
kevin cloud
can you see who played punjab yeah yeah
let's see
is it say oh played by jeffrey holder
oops he's certainly a black man a black
man
but i think back then they didn't have a
lot of guys
i feel like that's when they make that
kind of choice this is like the most
racist move actually 1982 yeah maybe
yeah i don't think
it's the closest they had
in 1982 there's probably i can't tell if
this is the most racist thing anyone's
done or like
is it worse if it's a white actor
because 1982
not a lot of ethnic actors
yeah so you would have to go i mean i i
think i would have gone
mexican with a tan
right right yes jenny sanchez
johnny no he's too hot
and he's too also creepy looking yeah
you got baggy eyes it would freak any
out [ __ ] backy eyes yeah he doesn't
have baggy eyes you'd freak any but the
greatest annie was
you start over no no
yeah yeah let's hold on let's do
something to wake each other up you do
one thing to me i do one thing to you
just improv game is it a physical thing
it can be physical just don't hurt me so
hard go ahead no you go first no you
have to go over here because i'm gonna
do something really sweet and nice and
then you're gonna slap me in the head
sounds physical okay okay
what all right for the audio listeners
uh george i can't you tell them
i just did it i missed it george i
touched her left breast
why the left not the right
i was just farther to reach with my
right oh some more about yeah right i'm
like which one this is shorter okay yeah
yeah but now you do your thing okay come
here to your left testicle
all right now right now kalala's looking
at bobby
she has both fingers oh
she put both wow fingers are my nose
yeah yeah
let's just do something like a pinch or
something so you always go for the hard
[ __ ] after okay go go go go hurt me hurt
me i'm gonna do a thwack
yeah do with the whack
jesus oh [ __ ] a thwack or a
[Laughter]
it's just so dry though it's to help you